traveling is less and less expensive
since the advent of the internet and
online booking consumers
no longer benefit from the same guarantees
and protections as for trips
organized via a
traditional travel agent MEPs have clarified
the rules of a market  highly
competitive
investigation on
a saturday morning the airport of brussels
géraldine and bujard leave for a
romantic mini trip
so suddenly leaves for tunisia at the zorro
bail at port el kantaoui
we therefore booked in a
travel agency a small package so a mini
trip  we return Tuesday morning so we stay
three nights there
and if now their flight was
strongly delayed or canceled what would
you do should he cancel their vacation
or lose the cost of the trip
would be long and a little late here is a
lot of delay we know  nothing to do we
wait if now the plane is canceled
that name we call an agency that
would do what is necessary to block a
flight is
postponed for the night  hotel ts or where to
reimburse them if now that's it if it's
lost no problem the plane is then
destination the sun
this security is for package tours
booked via a tour operator
or a travel agent on the other hand for
travelers who book themselves
online the European law of the 90s
does not protect them from new rules
more favorable to consumers using
the net have been approved by
MEPs
this situation highlights above all
the obligation to inform in a
clear and  transparent consumers that
the consumer knows before booking
what he is booking with whom he is
booking and in the event of a problem who will
be held responsible and that he must
contact even today certain
players take advantage of the loopholes in the
isabelle julphar law in  had the bitter
experience
she wanted to fly to venice
from belgium with a low cost company
I go to their site and saw that we
could book e  t the flight take
insurance i write the
highest insurance transfers from the airport to the
central station in chad in this case
since my hotel was based near the
station are in lucia is also the parking
my car during  the five days of the
stay all this was booked on their
site was paid in one go was
debited from my credit card the
same day but the company canceled the flight a
few days after the new
times proposed by the company were not
suitable  not isabelle she
therefore asks for reimbursement of these costs
I was very surprised when I received a
reimbursement I only received
reimbursement for the flight no
reimbursement
insurance that was taken on the site
no reimbursement from hamburg for the
transfer of  the airport to the station
or reimbursement of parking lots for my
car and the situation is completely
blocked because well they don't want
to reimburse they claim that
their condition is reimbursement  ser
only the flight isabelle is ready to
go to court to be
reimbursed if the new directive
had entered into force the company
would have the obligation to reimburse the
various services since isabelle
to book via the same website and
pay in one go in  less than 24 hours
customer service I find it really
lamentable because in fact you only have the
means to reach them with a
telephone number which is surcharged at 1 euro per
minute for the couple on vacation in
Tunisia their trip is happening  much
better everything is taken care of in the
package transport from the airport to
the hotel and even an excursion
here in the case of one to do the
tour operators also see
contracts with the hotels where I think
I have  completely separated with taxes
etc
in the end I spent the less expensive
and then this you to that inherited
in itself a surprise we have to say we are so
happy tour operators and
travel agents everywhere  the same
applies to unfair competition
from holiday booking websites these sites
must not take out insurance
to cover travelers travel agency
must pay premiums premiums which
are calculated according
to turnover and according to risk
compared to geneva someone who who who
would sell on the internet and who
obviously do not stop everything it's
all these restrictions it is clear that
in the final blow there is a
repercussion and among these guarantees
offered by the professionals of the  travel
that of the failure of a hotel or
staff strike which does not
necessarily cover a hotel reservation
by internet
if there is a staff strike
but
apart from turning to the management of
the hotel this  what I imagine
most customers will do there is obviously not a
lot of shopping and that he is
spared even looking for another hotel
the rest of his life the MEPs
still have to convince the
member states of the usefulness of these new
rules a long-awaited law
if géraldine and bigeard had booked
the various stages of their journey
on the internet and there had been a
problem with the plane he might have ended
up at the  departure point at
the airport without solution or
refund